eeuu desembolsa cada año cerca de
600.000 millones de dólares en materia
militar si hiciésemos una lista con los
países que más gastan en defensa en todo
el mundo por supuesto que estados unidos
es tenían primer lugar pero es que
además gastaría más que los 11 siguiente
países juntos de la lista que validarla
dentro de este desorbitado por supuesto
podemos encontrar equipamiento militar
tan sofisticado y poderoso como el
bombardero b2 spirit diseñado en plena
guerra fría con la misión de arrasar la
urss en caso de que fuera necesario y
que costó a los contribuyentes más de
77.000 millones de dólares
esta enzima sin incluir el costo
operativo del avión que alcanza la
friolera de 150 mil dólares cada hora de
vuelo
también tenemos como ejemplo la clase
force de portaaviones el barco más caro
jamás construido que cuenta con dos
reactores nucleares y estará preparado
para albergar a los últimos cazas de
quinta generación según los planes del
gobierno este proyecto tendría un coste
total de 140 mil millones de dólares
pero esto no es nada comparado con el
que se ha convertido el proyecto militar
más caro de la historia del mundo el
f-35
solo el coste de desarrollo ronda a los
400 mil millones de dólares para que os
hagáis una idea con este dinero
podríamos ir a la bolsa y hacernos con
el control de todas las empresas del
ibex-35 de un plumazo
hoy en visual político vamos a hablar de
este peculiar avión el f-35 el
archienemigo del contribuyente americano
cuando se levantará el ministro de
defensa y responderá por el fiasco del
f-35 donde está su responsabilidad todo
nace en 1996 con el ejército de eeuu
decide sacar a concurso la producción de
un avión polivalente capaz de hacer de
todo
es por eso por lo que el f-35 cuenta con
tres versiones diferentes por un lado
tenemos el f-35 ha destinado la fuerza
aérea pensado especialmente para el
combate aire aire y que sustituirá a los
f-16 el que ha sido el avión más exitoso
en la historia de los eeuu con más de
cuatro mil quinientas unidades crucis
por otro lado tenemos al f 35b la
variante que posee la capacidad de
despegar y aterrizar verticalmente y que
sustituirá a los harriers y a los f-18
hornet del cuerpo de marines en tercer y
último lugar tenemos al f 35 ce la
versión con alas de mayor tamaño y
plegables lo que le permite ser
embarcada y que sustituirá a los f-18 de
la marina de los eeuu
y
pero desde que el año 2001 la
multinacional americana lockheed martin
empezará a desarrollar este proyecto
todo han sido baches en el camino desde
que se adjudicó se han ya más
de 15 años
algunos países han llegado a cancelar
los encargos que tenían y el presupuesto
se ha ido a más del doble del inicial
por otro lado el pentágono saca pecho de
la capacidad de camuflaje de este nuevo
avión 3 ni embargo otros se harían hasta
criticar las capacidades técnicas de
combate que este super avión pueden
llegar a tener le han puesto unas alas
ridículas que le permiten despegar
verticalmente pero que le imposibilita
maniobrar en combate wing necesitas alas
para crear sustentación no sin alas no
hay giros eso hace el avión del todo
imposible de maniobrar pero spray ha
sido analista para el departamento de
defensa de los eeuu y ccoo diseñador de
aviones tan exitosos como el f16 o el a
10 por lo tanto su opinión tiene algo de
valor pero vale puede que no sea tipo
más imparcial es comentarista casi fijo
de base de today y llegamos visto mis
anteriores que hay detrás de todo ello
pero al en cuestionaría el compromiso y
la credibilidad de alguien como el
senador y candidato a la casa blanca por
el partido republicano john mccain john
mccain es otro gran crítico de este
proyecto same time we have to live a la
trayectoria del proyecto del f-35 ha
sido tanto un escándalo como una
tragedia en cuanto a coste calendario
así es john mccain da totalmente en el
clavo como ha podido una compañía
adjudicataria como lockheed llegar a
donde ha llegado el pentágono afirma que
este proyecto es tan grande que ya no
tenemos atrás ya no puede fallar pero
sin embargo yo me pregunto cómo ha
podido llegar esto a ser tan grande como
es sin que nadie haya puesto ningún tipo
de freno los números son para quitar la
respiración de hecho lo son literalmente
hace un par de meses un general de las
fuerzas aéreas encargado de los
presupuestos se desmayó mientras estar
dando una rueda de prensa sobre el f-35
efecto 10 esto es lo que tendrá el f-35
pero qué ha pasado con todo ese dinero a
dónde se ha ido os acordáis de la
empresa pública de este proyecto el
lockheed martin la que hemos hablado
antes bueno pues parece que sus
propietarios no nos ha ido nada mal de
hecho les ha ido genial desde que todo
esto empezara en 2001 la empresa ha
multiplicado su valor por seis de hecho
si miramos las cotizaciones de esta
empresa en bolsa veremos que esos
propietarios habían obtenido una
rentabilidad del 500 42 por ciento en
tan sólo una década para que os hagáis
una idea en el mismo tramo de tiempo
el s p500 ha rendido un 70
wow qué narices pasa con esta empresa de
armamento que lleva 52 semanas subiendo
en la bolsa en este mercado con todos
los recortes del presupuesto de defensa
pero están acá vacía muchas de las
piezas de el m35 se subcontratan a
empresas como a fenol pues bien en este
caso sus propietarios no eran x 6 su
valor en bolsa se habría multiplicado
por diez
lockheed martin nunca olvidamos para
quien trabajamos lo mejor de todo que el
negocio no acaba más que empezar y es
que se estima que para cuando este
programa termine que tiene 55 años de
vida los contribuyentes habrán
desembolsado un total de un billón y
medio de dólares pero éste estará lista
el último 2035 será entregado en 2040 no
comprendo cómo esta estrategia tiene
sentido comprar un avión de combate con
un diseño de 40 años de antigüedad con
todo lo que este comité ha sabido sobre
como nuestros potenciales adversarios
están rápidamente alcanzando nos y en
algunos casos igualando las ventajas
tecnológicas militares americanas pero
la verdad para mí esto es una gran es
una gran estafa producto de una vez más
del capitalismo de amiguetes acaso
podemos meter bajo el manto de la
seguridad todo tipo de cosas sin límite
y sin control espero que os haya gustado
este vídeo si tienes cualquier
comentario no dudéis en hacerlo y nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo un saludo en
visual política estamos a punto de
alcanzar los mil suscriptores y queremos
celebrarlo de una forma muy especial con
todos vosotros como últimamente no hacen
más que salir noticias sobre los panamá
papers hemos pensado que podríamos hacer
un vídeo respondiendo a todas las dudas
que podáis tener sobre la evasión fiscal
cualquier pregunta que tengáis nos la
podéis enviar a través de nuestra página
de facebook o mandando nos un mensaje
privado al canal de youtube esperamos
vuestros mensajes